CONTINUE TO SAY THAT- THAT THAT
ROUGHLY 50% OF ALL NEW CASES
ARE. TAKING PLACE IN FOUR
STATES AND SO AS YOU WOULD
ANTICIPATE- WERE WE ARE.
WORKING WITH GOVERNORS- AND
STATE HEALTH OFFICIALS IN ALL
THE STATES THAT ARE IMPACTED
BUT WE'RE PARTICULARLY FOCUSED.
IN OF FORT STATE'S- THAT ARE
GENERATING- THE MAJORITY OF THE
CASES WHICH COURSER CALIFORNIA
TEXAS. BORDER I'M I'M PLEASED
TO SEE THAT WELL THERE ARE TWO
NINES THAT HAVE. DON'T HAVE A
COMBINATION OF RISING
POSITIVITY AND RISING CASES- WE
ALSO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL TEN
STATES THAT ARE EITHER.
ENTIRELY STABLE OR HAVE NUMBERS
THAT ARE SO LOW THAT THERE TO
MINIMIZE SO OUR FOCUS
PARTICULARLY AT THE TASK FORCE
TODAY WAS ON THE TWELVE STATES
THAT HAVE THE COMBINATION. MMHM
BEYOND THAT- WHILE ONE LIFE
LOST IS TOO MANY AND WE MOURN
THE LOSS OF EVERY. AMERICAN
AND- GRIEVE WITH EVERY FAMILY
THAT LOST A LOVED ONE BECAUSE
OF THE DEDICATION OF OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS BECAUSE OF. OUR
RESPONSE AND THE RESPONSE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE- WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT TODAY- FIDELITY'S
ARE AT THE LOWEST LEVEL SINCE-
THE END OF MARCH- WE CONTINUE
TO BE VIGILANT AS WE SEE RISING
CASES- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
COULD. THAT COULD CHANGE BUT-
AGAIN TO SEE THE OF. OF THE
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN
FATALITIES. IS A TRIBUTE TO FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND- TO THE CORPORATION
IN THE COMPACTION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. OUR MESSAGE TO
EVERY AMERICAN IN THE IN THE
STATES THAT ARE MOST AFFECTED.
BY RISING CASES AND RISING
POSITIVITY RATES. IS WE'RE WITH
YOU. WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNORS IN YOUR STATE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES. AND THE SUPPORT OF
TO MEET THIS MOMENT AND PROVIDE
THE LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE THAN
ANYONE OF US WOULD YOU WOULD
EXPECT FOR A MEMBER OF OUR
FAMILY- BUT TO ALL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE- I SAY OF. THE HALF OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND WHAT HOUSE BLACK AS
WELL BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
FORMER. READY. BETTER PLACE.
THEY WE WERE REFORM OR EVEN
MONTHS AGO PART OF OUR TODAY WE
TONDO FROM THAT WE MADE AND
BUILDING TO RESPOND. TO THE
OFFER THAT WAY SEEING A IN
STATE'S FOR TWO. ACROSS SOUTH.
FIVE HAVE BUT BEEN TRAVELING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I WAS A
ACTUALLY IN TEXAS OVER THIS
PAST THE WEEKEND RECEIVE THE
FULL BRIEFING FROM GOVERNOR
ABBOTT- ABOUT THE THEIR
RESPONSE- AND- I WILL BE
TRAVELING TO ARIZONA TOMORROW.
A MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR
DUCEY AND I'LL BE ABLE TO
CONFIRM TO HIM. THAT BORN TODAY
ARE EIGHTEEN DEPLOYED BY FEMA
OF SIXTY TO. A DISASTER MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PERSONNEL ARE ON THE
GROUND IN ARIZONA WERE ALSO
CURRENTLY PROCESSING- A REQUEST
FROM TEXAS AND MORE
CONSULTATION WITH OTHER STATES
AS YOU'LL HEAR IN A MOMENT-
WITH REGARD TO TESTING. WITH
REGARD TO PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WITH REGARD TO
VENTILATORS WITH REGARD TO
THERAPEUTIC MEDICINES WE ARE IN
A STRONG POSITION. ALL ACROSS
THE AFFECTED AREAS OF THE
COUNTRY TO MEET THIS MOMENT BUT
IN ADDITION WITH THE STATE'S-
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE
REINFORCEMENTS IN HEALTHCARE
WORKERS- AND- AND I'M PLEASED
TO. TODAY THAT THE SIXTY TWO-
D. MAP OR DISASTER MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAM MEMBERS HAVE
ARRIVED ARIZONA ALSO BE
TRAVELING THIS WEEK. TO STAY OF
FOR. WE'RE PERSON ALL. ONE A
ABOUT THAT CONSTITUTES RESPONSE
AT THE PRESENT MOMENT FIFTY IN
THE ARE REAL AND HAVE DONE SO
IN 1 DEGREES OR ANOTHER SENSE
OF THE BEGINNING OF MAY WHEN WE
ISSUED OUR GUIDELINES TO OPEN
UP AMERICA AGAIN AT THIS MOMENT
IN TIME BECAUSE OF THE RISING
CASES AT LEAST FOUR STATES HAVE
TAKEN ACTION TO CLOSE DOWN BARS
LIMIT CAPACITY IN RESTAURANTS-
AND- AND ANOTHER TEN STATES
HAVE SLOW DOWN OR POSTPONE
CERTAIN RE OPENING EFFORTS AND-
AND LET ME JUST MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
NEW GUIDANCE IT'S BEEN ISSUED.
BY THE GOVERNORS IN THE STATES-
WE TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT THESE
THESE PRUDENT MEASURES AND
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE AND STEPS
WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE OUR NATION
FORWARD CAN YOU RE OPEN- IN A
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE WAY WHILE
PUTTING THE HEALTH THE HEALTH
OF OUR CITIZENS FIRST I THOUGHT
DOCTOR FELT SHE- OF PUT IT
WELL- IN A WRITTEN TEST FORCE
MEETING WHEN- HE SAID AND I
THINK ALSO TESTIFIED TODAY THAT
WE SHOULD NOT LOOK AT SAFETY
MEASURE DOESN'T PEDIMENT
OPENING UP. AMERICA THE REP TO
LOOK AT THE V. TWO UP. AS WE
SEE RISING K. OF THOSE. TWELVE
STATES WHERE WE HAVE A- OF
RIGHTS THIS IS AN- AND
POSITIVITY- THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW THAT OUR BEST
HEALTH EXPERTS SAY IT'S NOT AN
EITHER OR- IT'S NOT WHETHER WE
CONTINUE TO OPEN UP OR WHETHER
WE- MOVE IN OPPOSITE DIRECTION
BUT RATHER IT'S WHETHER WE-
TAKE THESE. PRUDENT MEASURES
THAT. THAT WILL OF SLOW THE
SPREAD AND PUT THE HEALTH. OF
OUR CITIZENS FIRST- OUR
GOVERNORS IN THE AFFECTED AREAS
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
ARE MAKING. ARE IN STRONG
ACTION TO KEEP THEIR STATE'S
OPEN. A WALL WHILE SLOWING THE
SPREAD AND- AND PUTTING THE
HEALTH OF THEIR CITIZENS FIRST
AND THEY HAVE R. SUPPORT. LET
ME SAY AGAIN AS I SAID AT THE
OUTSET- AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
TO KNOW THAT WE'RE IN A MUCH
BETTER PLACE TODAY. THANKS TO
THE WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT.
APPROACH THE WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
INITIATED AT THE VERY OUTSET.
OF THE CORONAVIRUS A PANDEMIC-
THE- IN WORKING IN COOPERATION
WITH. AGENCIES ACROSS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WORKING
WITH PRIVATE SECTOR ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY- WE LITERALLY HAVE
SCALED NOW THIRTY THREE MILLION
TESTS. HAVE BEEN PERFORMED
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES. AND
THE ELS- EMMA BRITCHER R. WILL
DETAIL MOMENTARILY WE'RE WE'RE
TESTING BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH
THE CAPACITY. TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THAT THROUGH THE
INNOVATION OF WHAT IS KNOWN. AS
PULLING. AND WHEN IT COMES TO
MEDICAL SUPPLIES- FEMA HAS-
FACILITATED THE DELIVERY OF
LITERALLY BILLIONS OF GLOVES
AND GOWNS AND MASKS AND- AS
GENERAL POLL OF CHECK WILL LET
DETAIL IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS WE
ARE. IN CONTINUOUS CONTACT.
WITH NOT JUST STATE'S BUT WITH
HOSPITALS IN STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WE CONTINUE TO RECEIVE.
VERY STRONG SUPPORT REPORTS
ABOUT. OF THE SUPPORT THEY'VE
RECEIVED IN THE SUPPLIES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO ME AT THIS
MOMENT. ALSO WE'RE IN A MUCH
BETTER PLACE BECAUSE OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF WHAT'S KNOWN AS
THERAPEUTICS OR MEDICINES. TO
TREAT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CONTRACTED THE CORONAVIRUS ARE
EXPERIENCING. A SEVERE
SYMPTOMS- THE DOCTOR STEVE HAHN
OF THE FDA IS HERE AND HE WILL
SPEAK ABOUT. THE PROGRESS THAT.
THAT WE ARE MAKING- IF WHETHER
IT BE A BATTLE BILITY OF DEBT.
WHICH WERE DISTRIBUTING ANOTHER
TRUMP'S THIS WEEK. THE USE OF
BLOOD PLASMA STEROID TREATMENTS
AND- AND ALSO WE CAN DO TO HEAR
VERY. SIGNS ABOUT THE CONTINUE.
CONTINUING PROGRESS FOR
DEVELOPING A VACCINE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE- AND SPOKE.
WITH THAT I'M GONNA I'M GOING
TO YIELD. TO THE- YOU UPDATES
ON BEGIN WITH SECRETARY ARE WHO
LOVE. ON OUR NATIONAL RISK AND
IMP WORK THE CD'S DID TO WITH
HER TO OPENING UP OUR SCHOOLS
AGAIN AND- AND THEN- AND ROLL
THE JUROR WILL UPDATE US ON
TESTING AND RIPPLE OF CHECK. ON
SUPPLIES DR HAN ON MEDICINES.
AND THEN FINALLY WILL WE'LL
HEAR FROM DR JEROME ADAMS IS
SURGEON GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES. WHO WILL GIVE A COUNCIL
TO OF EVERY AMERICAN. IN THE
STATES THAT ARE IMPACTED AND
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY ABOUT
ABOUT BEST PRACTICES. AND SO
TO- TO EVERY AMERICAN IN STATES
THAT ARE SEEING RISING CASES
AND- AND RISING TRENDS IN
POSITIVITY WE WANT WE WANT TO
ASSURE YOU WE'RE WITH YOU. AND
WE'RE CALLING IT INSTEAD. IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MEET
THIS MOMENT AND WORKING IN
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH YOUR
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS. AND
EVERY AMERICAN. WE WANT TO
ASRE YOU THAT WE'RE READY.
MORE READY THAN EVER BEFORE. TO
MEET THIS CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
BECAUSE OF THE- BECAUSE OF THE
RESOURCES- THAT OUR PRESIDENT
OF THE AGENCIES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE STEPS AND
DEPLOYED EFFORTS AT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND- AND MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE DONE AND
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO. I MEAN THE TRUTH
IS- WELL WE'VE WE'VE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS ON MAKING AVAILABILITY
TESTING AND SUPPLIES AND-
MEDICINES WE ALL NEED TO DO OUR
PART. WE KNOW HOW TO SLOW THE
SPREAD. AND THE COMMON SENSE
MEASURES SHOWED THAT- THAT WE
OUTLINED. IN OUR PHASED
APPROACH TO OPEN UP AMERICA
AGAIN THE GUIDELINES THAT APPLY
TO ALL OF THE PHASES. ARE OUGHT
TO BE EMBRACED BY EVERY
AMERICAN- WASH YOUR HANDS
PRACTICE GOOD HYGIENE. IT WEAR
A MASK. I'LL WEAR A MASK OF
WHEN- WHENEVER YOU'RE STATE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES SAY IT'S
APPROPRIATE GEORGE ALWAYS A
GOOD IDEA TO WEAR A MASK WHEN
SOCIAL DISTANCING- IS NOT
POSSIBLE- WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND WE HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE. THAT THIS- AS AS WE
MET AT THE MOMENT BEFORE WHEN
WE SAW THIS PANDEMIC FIRST
STRIKE IN THE NORTH WEST. AND
THEN STRIKE SO HARD AROUND- THE
GREATER NEW YORK CITY AREA THEN
NEW ORLEANS AND MICHIGAN. WITH
A WITH A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH A WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH CORPORATION THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. WE'LL DO WHAT
WE DID EARLIER ON IN THIS
PANDEMIC OF WILL SLOW THE
SPREAD. AND WILL SAVE LIVES
WITH THAT- SECRETARY IS R. AND
MEMBERS THE TEAM A BRIEF AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS. THE SECTOR. WELL
THANK YOU MR VICE PRESIDENT FOR
HONORING HHS IN THE
COMMISSIONED CORPS WITH YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP OF THE
PRESIDENT'S ALL OF AMERICA
RESPONSE TO COVID NINETEEN. I
ALSO LIKE TO THANK ABBAS YOUR
WALL AND VICE ADMIRAL ADAMS FOR
THEIR SERVICE DURING THIS
CRISIS AND FOR THEIR DEDICATION
TO STRENGTHENING THE
COMMISSIONED CORPS. THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE COMMISSION CORA
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CENTRAL TO OUR COVID NINETEEN
RESPONSE. AND ALL SIX POINTS OF
OUR STRATEGY TO DEFEAT THE
VIRUS SURVEILLANCE TESTING.
CONTAINMENT HEALTH CARE
CAPACITY VACCINES AND
THERAPEUTICS. EVERY MEMBER OF
THE COMMISSION CORY WHO'S GONE
INTO HARM'S WAY IN THIS CRISIS
WHO SPENT TIME AWAY FROM HOME
AND LOVED ONES WE ARE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL. I WANT TO MENTION ONE
PARTICULAR STEP FORWARD WE TOOK
TODAY TO HELP AMERICANS GET
BACK TO WORK AND BACK TO SCHOOL
WHILE PROTECTING US FROM THE
VIRUS. NEW GUIDANCE FROM THE
CDC AS TO HOW HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS CAN PROTECT
STUDENTS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
IN PARTICULAR IT OFFERS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW AND
WHEN TESTING SHOULD BE USED FOR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
INCLUDING BOTH TESTING FOR
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS AND
TESTING FOR A SYMPTOMATIC
INDIVIDUALS. WHO HAD POSSIBLE
EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS. THE GODS
ALSO NOTES THAT IN AREAS WITH
MODERATE TO SUBSTANTIAL
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION WHERE
RESOURCES ALLOW. COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN WORK WITH
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
CONSIDER TESTING A SYMPTOMATIC
STUDENTS AND STAFF OF NO KNOWN
EXPOSURE. THIS MAY MAKE SENSE
IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY OUTBREAKS
AND INFORM CONTROL MEASURES AND
WOULD ESPECIALLY APPLY TO
GROUPS LIKE THOSE LIVING IN
CONGREGATE HOUSING. THIS GUNS
RELIES ON WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
ABOUT THE VIRUS IN RECENT
MONTHS. IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
WE WILL ALSO BE RELEASING
SIMILAR GUIDES RUN K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS RECOGNIZING HOW
IMPORTANT SAFE SCHOOLS ARE TO
RE OPENING OUR COUNTRY. THESE
ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF THE
SCIENCE BASED RESOURCES THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING FOR STATE. AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONS AS THEY WORK
WITH FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. TO
CONTINUE THE FIGHT AGAINST THE
VIRUS AND RE OPEN OUR COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO REOPEN AMERICA. WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK BACK
TO SCHOOL BACK TO WORSHIP BACK
TO HEALTH CARE. BUT WE MUST ALL
PLAY OUR INDIVIDUAL PARTS TO
ENABLE THIS REOPENING. WE CAN
REVERSE THESE OUTBREAKS AND
PREVENT FUTURE ONES BY DOING
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS CALLED
FOR SINCE THE BEGINNING IN HIS
GUIDANCE. PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. WEAR FACIAL
COVERINGS WERE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS NOT POSSIBLE AND
PRACTICE GOOD PERSONAL HYGIENE.
BY DOING SO YOU PROTECT
YOURSELF YOU PROTECT VULNERABLE
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS. BUT YOU ALSO
PROTECT THE PERSON YOU MAY BE
STANDING NEXT TO IN THE GROCERY
LINE AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE VULNERABLE YOU HAVE NO
WAY OF KNOWING WHETHER THEY'RE
AT HIGH RISK OF SEVERITY
HOSPITALIZATION OR FINALITY YOU
PROTECT THEM. THEY'RE JUST
THREE SIMPLE STEPS. TO KEEP
REOPENING. SOCIAL DISTANCE.
WEAR FACIAL COVERINGS WHEN YOU
CAN'T SOCIAL DISTANCE AND
PRACTICE GOOD PERSONAL HYGIENE.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED TO DO TO
KEEP RE OPENING WE CAN WORK SGT
GO TO SCHOOL. GO TO WORSHIP RE
ENGAGE WITH HEALTH CARE IF WE
ALL AS INDIVIDUALS PRACTICE
GOOD RESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOR TO
PROTECT EACH OTHER AND TO
PROTECT OURSELVES. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WHICH WAS PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MR VICE PRESIDENT
MISTER SECRETARY AGAIN YOU DID
THIS INCREDIBLE HONOR BY BEING
HERE AND HONORING AND
APPRECIATING THE SIX THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED. WOMEN AND MEN OF
THE COMMISSIONED CORPS WE DO
SAY WOMEN AND MEN WE ARE 55%
FEMALE SERVICE- IN THE MOST
DIVERSE WITHIN THE COUNTRY. I'M
GONNA TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
TALK ABOUT TESTING AS BOTH THE
VICE PRESIDENT THE SECRETARY
SAID WE'RE- OVERALL DIFFERENT
THAN WE WERE IN MARCH THAT TIME
IN EARLY MARCH WOULD ONLY DONE
A FEW THOUSAND TASKS. NOW WE'RE
DOING FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND WE'VE
ACTUALLY GONE OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER DAY ON OCCASION
OVER THIRTY THREE MILLION TASKS
I THINK ALL YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME COMPONENTS TO THIS.
THEY'RE SORT OF THE FRONT END
SOMEBODY TO TAKE A SWAB OR TO
SUPERVISE YOU DOING THAT'S WHY
I'M GONNA HAVE THE SUPPLIES
THERE YOU GOT TO HAVE THE
MACHINES AND YOU GOT TO HAVE A
LABORATORY TEST. SO ON THE
FRONT END. WAY BACK IN MARCH
THIS HAD TO BE DONE BY A
PRACTITIONER. WITH A VERY DEEP
NASOPHARYNGEAL SWAB IN FULL PP.
WE COULD NOT GET TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. FROM THERE WITHOUT A
LOT OF SCIENCE AND A LOT OF
COLLABORATION FROM THE FDA.
BECAUSE WE'RE ABLE TO VALIDATE
NASAL SELF SWAPPING THOSE FORTY
ONE SITES TURNED INTO WHAT YOU
SAW TODAY IN THE PRESS. OVER
SIX HUNDRED RETAIL PHARMACY
SITES THAT HAVE NOW BEEN
EXTENDED FOR SEVERAL MONTHS-
CONTINUING FROM THEIR- FIRST
JUNE THIRTIETH CLOSURE NOW AT
LEAST THROUGH AUGUST. WHERE
THEY'RE SUPERVISED SELF
SWAPPING THAT HAS TRANSLATED
INTO ANOTHER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
CDS SITES SO NOW TWO THOUSAND
RETAIL PHARMACY SITES. BORN
FROM THOSE FIRST FORTY ONE IN
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED-
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER SITES AGAIN MOST OF
THESE FOCUSED ON THE MOST-
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. SO
WE'RE SCALING THAT IN EVERY
WEEK WE'RE GETTING NEW
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE FDA
OUGHT TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP
FURTHER AND THAT'S HOME SELF'S
WHOPPING. THERE ARE SOME
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT ARE HOME
SELF SWABBING IN SOME BETTER
VIDEO ASSISTED SO WE COULD
ELIMINATE A LOT OF THE WHOLE
FRONT END PROBLEM WHERE WE ARE.
AS I SAID MANY TIMES WE'RE IN
SCALING TESTING ON A ROUTINE
BASIS. AND I'VE TOLD YOU THAT
ASSUMING NO TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS WE WILL EASILY BE
AT FORTY TO FIFTY MILLION TEST
AVAILABLE- BY SEPTEMBER. THAT'S
A VERY CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE
VERY CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE
BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY TELLS US
WE'LL BE AT A MUCH HIGHER
PLACE. BUT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
INNOVATIONS WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW BEING IMPLEMENTED AGAIN
UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF THE FDA.
VALIDATED HIGH QUALITY R. AND
THAT'S PULLING YOU'VE HEARD
YOU'VE HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT
PULLING. PULLING IT'S VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE IT COULD
COMBINED OF MORE THAN ONE
SAMPLE. IN A SINGLE LABORATORY
ASI SO IMAGINE THE SITUATION
WHERE I WANTED TO KNOW IF ALL
YOU WERE WERE POTENTIALLY
NEGATIVE AND I THOUGHT YOU WERE
PROBABLY NEGATIVE BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE A HISTORY YOU'RE
NOT- FEBBRAIO YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
IN CONTACT WITH ANYONE. SO YOU
COULD COLLECT YOUR OWN SWABS
YOU CAN PUT THEM INTO AND WE
CAN TAKE ALL THOSE TUBES ARE AT
LEAST TEN OF THEM. INTO A
SINGLE TO BEEN DO THAT ASKING.
IF THAT ONE SINGLE ASKED
NEGATIVE THEN YOU'RE ALL
NEGATIVE IF YOU DO IT
APPROPRIATELY SO YOU CAN
LEVERAGE. TWO TIMES FIVE TIMES
POSSIBLY EVEN UP TO TEN TIMES
OR EVEN MORE THIS IS BEING DONE
NOW IN MANY UNIVERSITIES AND
MANY PERSONAL LABORATORIES AND
WE ABSOLUTELY WORK WITH EVERY
IN THE TWO EIGHTY THIS IS NOT
RIGHT ALL THE TIME. BUT IT'S
RIGHT UP OF THE TIME SO THOSE
EIGHTY TWENTY BILLION TASK PER
MONTH THAT WILL WE BE DOING OUR
O. Y. PART OF THIS THIRTY FIVE
TO FIFTY SIXTY MILLION TESTS
WERE DOING IT NUMBER. YOU DO
THAT AFTER MULTIPLY POLICE
REPORT. TO CONFIRM SO WHAT IS
GOING GET A THE FINAL THING I
WANT SAY. IS THE REAL EXPERTS
THAT'S THREE THEY DIE DI DI NOT
PROGRAM AND I. AS WELL AS THE
BY MEDICALLY RESEARCH DEVELOP
OF AUTHORITY ARE REALLY MAKING
GREAT INROADS TO INNOVATION-
THIS WAS FUNDED TO SORT OF GET
US TO THE NEXT STEP TO PROVIDE
MORE RAPID TESTS HIGHER
QUANTITIES OF TEST COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TESTS. NOW
AGAIN WE'RE NOT ASSUMING ANY
BREAKTHROUGH INNOVATIONS- BUT
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME AND I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT- THE
NIH DIRECTOR FRANCIS COLLINS
DEPARTED DIRECTOR DOCTOR KERRY
SPREADER WHEN I WORK ON
LITERALLY ON A DAILY BASIS TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THE INNOVATIONS
THAT COME ON WILL BE TRANSLATED
IMMEDIATELY TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM SO- I'LL BE HAPPY
TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS LATER
ON. THANK YOU FOR. WELL THANK
IMAGER THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
YOUR GREAT EFFORTS I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR. PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY WHEN EXPRESS SO
PROUD WE ARE FOR. THE
EXTRAORDINARY PROGRESS. THE WAY
WE SCALE TESTING ACROSS AMERICA
IS HISTORIC. WHEN I WAS SET TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WE HAD
DONE LESS THAN. EIGHT THOUSAND
CORONAVIRUS TESTS AND TO THINK
THAT IN THE INTERVENING MONTHS
NOW THIRTY THREE MILLION TIMES.
AND THE ABILITY TO SCALE BEYOND
THAT IT'S A IT IS A GREAT
COMFORT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE-
AND IN A GREAT TRIBUTE. A GREAT
TRIBUTE TO THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP FORGED EARLY ON. I THINK
IT'S ALSO BEEN HIS STORE TO SEE
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
OUR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND PARTICULARLY FOR
AMERICANS- IN THE IN THE FOUR
STATES WHERE 50% OF THE CASES
ARE OCCURRING WITH THE TWELVE
STATE'S REVERSING A
COMBINATION. OF RISING CASES
AND POSITIVE AND I WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW. THAT
THE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE FOR OUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. ALSO AT.
LEVEL AND I'VE ASKED AT JOHN
PLOT CHECK TO COME. INTO
ARTICULATE WHERE WE STAND
TODAY- WITH THE HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. IN THE
IMPACTED AREAS AND- IN OUR
ONGOING EFFORTS TO ENSURE- THAT
THE EXTRAORDINARY DOCTORS AND
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
THAT ARE AT THIS VERY HOUR.
MINISTERING TO AMERICANS OF
STRUGGLING WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS. I HAVE THE MASKS
THE GROUNDS THE GLOVES
VENTILATORS AND ALL THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED TO RENDER THAT CARE.
BUT I'M A PROJECT. THANK YOU MR
VICE PRESIDENT OF. THEY HAD
BEEN BACK IN MARCH THE MARCH
WHEN I WAS MOVE FOR THE
PENTAGON TO- TO FEMALE THE
PRESIDENT GAVE ME ON ONE TASK-
PROVIDER HEALTHCARE WORKERS-
THE SUPPLIES THEY NEED- WHAT
THEY NEED. WHEN THEY NEED IT.
AND I THOUGHT CAN YOU GIVE ME A
SHORT UPDATE TODAY- AND I THINK
THE TEAM IS- M. WE HAVE MORE
AND THEY HAVE MORE. SO FROM-
FROM THAT TIME IN MARCH AMID
MARCH UNTIL NOW WE ARE IN A
FUNDAMENTALLY- BETTER POSITION.
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH SOME
DETAILS- THAT THAT THAT MAKES
ME THAT- IF THEY'RE CONFIDENT-
AND I PERSONALLY THOSE A PERSON
I KNOW ME I MIGHT IN MY GLASS
HALF FULL TYPE OF PERSON- AND
SO- FIVE FOR THESE- THESE
DETAILS I FIND VERY ENCOURAGING.
AS WE OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS-
TRY TO ASCERTAIN. HOW WELL.
STATES IN HOSPITAL NETWORKS OR
PREPARING- IN PREPARING FOR. ON
THE SUMMER INTO THE FALL WE
HELD A ROUND OF. OF STATE CALLS
WITH EVERY STATE EMERGENCY
MANAGER. IN EVERY STATE HEALTH
OFFICIAL FACILITATED BY THE
FEMA REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR SO-
WE WENT THROUGH EVERY REGION.
AND EVERY STATE. WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT- WHAT WE WERE
DOING FOR THE NATIONAL
STOCKPILE IN WHAT THEY WERE
DOING FOR THEIR STATES. THAT
CALL LED ME TO BELIEVE THAT
65270% OF THE STATES HAVE AT
LEAST THIRTY DAYS A SUPPLY ON
HAND IF NOT SIXTY. ARE THERE
MANY STATES THAT HAVE MORE THAN
SIXTY THAT HAVE- TARGETS OF
NINETY AND ARE LOOKING TO
ACHIEVE THAT. THOSE STATE
CALLS- BUT I'VE FELT MY ME
CONFIDENT OF THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING INTO OUR- I'M
MODERNIZE NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
HERE IN RECENT WEEKS WITH THE
UPTICK IN CASES. WHERE DR
BERKSHIRE'S HIGHLIGHTED A DOWN
TO THE COUNTY LEVEL MY TEAM HAS
CALLED ON THOSE HOSPITALS. ARE
AND I AM HERE TO PROVIDE- A
SYNOPSIS OF THAT. WE'VE TALKED
ARSENALS IN DALLAS- PHOENIX
HOUSTON- AND ON DOWN THE LINE.
MANY OF THEM ALL REPORTING
THIRTY TO FORTY DAYS OF SUPPLY
OF ON NOW THERE ARE SOME
SPORADIC- SHORTAGES- BUT MOSTLY
IN THE SIZE OF- THE SIZE OF
MASKS- COULD I HAVE MORE SMALL
MASKS NOW SO WE TOOK THAT
INFORMATION AND I DID NOT TALK
TO THREE M. TODAY AS A MATTER
OF FACT- AND THEY'VE ALREADY
CHANGED BASED ON DISCUSSIONS
WITH MY TEAM. THEY'VE ALREADY
CHANGED THEIR PRODUCTION TO
PRODUCED MORE SMALL AND EXTRA
SMALL MASTER SENSUALLY- ALMOST
AN EVEN SPLIT 8550% MORE
SMALLS- AND IT TO THE END OF
TWO OF THE REST TO NORMAL
SUPPLIES ON SHOW STATE'S OR
SAYING THEY HAVE SUPPLIES.
HOSPITALS IN AREAS WHERE- THERE
ARE OUTBREAKS ARE HAVING MORE
SUPPLIES ANOTHER DENTAL- THEY
NATIONAL HEALTH SAFETY NETWORK-
WHERE THAT CDC RON- NETWORK
WHERE HOSPITALS REPORT DAYS
SUPPLIES ON HAND ACROSS THE
NATION- THOSE SUPPLIES BACK IN
MARCH THERE ARE MANY HOSPITALS
ARE SAYING THAT THEY HAVE LESS
THAN THREE DAYS NOW. FOLKS.
HAVE MULTIPLE WEEKS. YOUR WE
ARE. IN IT IF PLACE I'M- ONE OF
THE WE DID WAS WE JUST. ALL OF
THE BIG SYSTEM DATA FOR ON THE
MEDICAL SUPPLY CHAIN FOR THE
COMMERCIAL MEDICAL SUPPLY CHAIN
I HAVE THAT RESONATED FEMA. AND
I CAN SEE THE DEMAND. FROM
HOSPITALS. AND THE SUPPLY TO
THEM- AND THOSE NUMBERS ARE
COMING TOGETHER- WHERE SUPPLY
IS GETTING MUCH CLOSER. TO
MEANT TO HURT DEMAND. ALL AT
THE SAME TIME THIRTEEN STATES
ARE STOCKPILING MR PALLISER
STOCKPILING. HOSPITALS ARE
STOCKPILING AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THAT HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE. IS BEING.
REALLY BEING REPLACED. SHOW ME
A NEW SHIFT OFF TO NURSING HOME
IN THE DISTRICT WE'RE ON OUR
SECOND ROUND OF THE NURSING
HOME PROJECT- YOU KNOW THOSE
GIVE A- LITTLE BIT MORE THAN A
WEEK'S WORTH OF SUPPLY. EACH
EACH ROUND HAS A YOU KNOW
ALMOST TWO MILLION I AM A
CERTIFIED PRODUCTION FOURTEEN
MILLION MASKS SIXTY THREE
MILLION. GALLONS THE GLOVES-
AND THIRTEEN MILLION GALLONS TO
GET TO THE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PLUS NURSING HOMES ONE HOUR 60%
THROUGH THE SECOND ROUND AND I
IN 45% OF BEEN DELIVERED. AND
FINALLY LET ME JUST TOUCH ON
VENTILATORS- SO BACK IN MARCH
THIS DONE NATIONAL STOCKPILE
HAD APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TODAY READY
FOR DEPLOYMENT WE HAVE FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND. BY NEXT WEEK IF
THE PRODUCTION SCHEDULES HOLD.
WILL HAVE FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND.
WE ARE WE ARE IN A
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT PLACE
FOR SUPPLIES. ON THAT NOTE THAT
WE ARE- PENDING- YOUR QUESTIONS
LATER NATIONAL PRESENCE ON. IN
ONE OTHER AREA WHERE WE'VE-
MADE GREAT STRIDES AND WE HOPE.
AND PRAY TO MAKE GOOD STRIDES
IN THE MONTHS AHEAD HAS BEEN IN
THE AREA OF- THERAPEUTICS AND
IN THE HEADLONG PURSUIT OF
VACCINES WHEN WE SEE THE-
EXTRAORDINARY DECLINE IN
FATALITIES- OVER THE LAST TWO
MONTHS. IT IS A TRIBUTE FIRST
OR HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO ALL
THAT THEY'VE DONE- BUT IT'S
ALSO A TRIBUTE TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF- OF WHAT ARE
KNOWN AS THERAPEUTICS AND
MEDICINES LIKE ROUND DISAPPEARS
AND STEROID TREATMENT THAT YOU
ALL HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF. OF PLASMA
TREATMENTS AND- AND I WANTED TO
A DOCTOR STEVE HAHN OF THE FDA
TO UPDATE US ON THE ON THE
MEDICINES AS WELL AS WHERE WE
STAND ON VACCINES DR ON. THANK
YOU THANK MISTRUST PRESIDENT.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP- ASKED THE
FDA EARLY ON THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC TO REDUCE ANY
UNNECESSARY REGULATORY BARRIERS
TO GET MEDICAL PRODUCTS IN THE
HANDS OF AMERICANS. AND THE FDA
CREATING EMERGENCY REVIEW AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FOR
THERAPIES CALLED THE
CORONAVIRUS TREATMENT
ACCELERATION PROGRAM. AND WE
HAVE SUPPORTED THAT PROGRAM
SINCE THAT TIME AND CONTINUES
TO THIS DAY. LIKE TO FIRST
START BY TELLING THAT THE
PIPELINE OF THERAPEUTICS
TREATMENTS THAT WE SEE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY THE GREAT
ACADEMICS RESEARCHERS PRIVATE
SECTOR THAT PIPELINE IS VERY
ROBUST. CURRENTLY. CURRENTLY AS
A RECENT COUNT FTAS MARCHING
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR ACTIVE TRIALS OF
THERAPEUTIC AGENTS FOR COVID
NINETEEN AND ANOTHER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS FOR
THERAPEUTIC AGENTS IS IN THE
PIPELINE. SO WE'RE NOT VASTLY
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN WE WERE
THREE MONTHS AGO TWO MONTHS AGO.
THE NATION'S WORK IS PAYING OFF
AS WE SAW THE POSITIVE RESULTS
OF THE RECENT NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF ALLERGY
INFECTIOUS PROTECTIONS DISEASE
TRIAL RUN DOES APPEAR IN
CERTAIN HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS
WITH A SIGNIFICANT 30%
REDUCTION IN LENGTH OF HOSPITAL
STAY. FOR SEVERE COVID NINETEEN
PATIENTS WE ALSO RECENTLY
UPDATED THE CLINICAL GUIDELINES
FOR THE TREATMENT OF COVID
NINETEEN DISEASE WITH THE
ADDITION OF DEXAMETHASONE AND
OTHER CORTICOSTEROIDS. WITH A
TRIAL THAT REPORTED A 30%
REDUCTION IN MORTALITY AND
SEVERELY ILL PATIENTS. THOSE
TWO THERAPIES ALONE WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
NATURAL HISTORY IN THE COURSE
OF THIS DISEASE AND PROVIDES
GREAT HOPE FOR THOSE WHO GET
SICK WITH THIS AND ARE
HOSPITALIZED. BUT OUR WORK
ISN'T DONE MORE IS IN THE
PIPELINE AS I MENTIONED OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. PATIENTS
THE UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN
TREATED ON OUR END IT SAYS
CONVALESCENT PROGRAM. BUT JUST
AS REMINDER THAT'S WHERE WE
TAKE. THE ANTIBODIES YOU'RE NOT
HELLO BY SOME WHO HAS. GOTTEN
ACROSS NINETEEN AND THEN
RECOVER THE NAME OF MR TO
SOMEONE WHO SIX COVID NINETEEN
THIS IS WORK IN OTHER DISEASES
THE PAST. SOME PRELIMINARY IN
OVER THOUSAND PATIENTS. CHOSE
THEIR BASED. AM EVALUATING THE
EFFICACY OF THIS EFFECTIVENESS
OF THIS PROGRAM WE HAVE GREAT
FOR THAT. NOW THAT IN FROM WILL
TELL US A LOT ABOUT IT A PERSON
DEVELOPS. HOW PROTECTIVE ORDER
IN ABOUT WHAT LAY DO YOU KNOW.
AND IT ALSO GIVES US A IN FROM
FOR THE NEW SET OF THERAPEUTICS
THAT ARE COMING DOWN THE PIKE
ALREADY IN CLINICAL TRIALS WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF- OF AGENTS
CALLED MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES.
WHICH ARE SYNTHETIC FORMS OF
ANTIBODIES SO GENETICALLY
ENGINEERED ANTIBODIES THAT CAN
THEN BE GIVEN AGAIN HE'S BEEN
USING OTHER INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AND WE HAVE HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD ALSO WORK IN THE CITY'S
INCUMBENT NINETEEN. AND WE
EXPECT TO READ OUT OF THOSE
TRIALS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS POSSIBLY LATE SUMMER AND
EARLY FALL. I JUST WANNA SWITCH
GEARS TO TALK ABOUT VACCINES-
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
SECRETARY ETS ARE IN OPERATION
WORK SPEED- WE HAVE SEEN THE
SPONSORSHIP OF A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT VACCINES. BUT WE KNOW
THAT VACCINES ARE BEING
DEVELOPED AROUND THE WORLD AND
FDA HAS RECEIVED APPLICATIONS
FROM DOUBLE DIGIT NUMBER OF
SPONSORS REGARDING VACCINES.
FOR VACCINES HAVE BEEN APPROVED
FOR MOVING INTO CLINICAL TRIALS
THAT IS AUTHORIZED TO GO INTO
CLINICAL TRIALS SO WE CAN GET
THE DATA ON THOSE VACCINES.
ANOTHER SIX ARE IN THE PIPELINE
FOR US TO REVIEW. WE SEEN
RECENT REPORTS OF INTERESTING
AND I THINK POSITIVE DATA
REGARDING THE IMMUNOGENICITY.
THAT IS HOW WELL THESE VACCINES
A STIMULATING IMMUNITY AND
IMMUNE RESPONSE IN PEOPLE AND
ALSO REGARDING THEIR SAFETY.
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT
I THINK WE'VE SEEN SOME
POSITIVE RESULTS TO DATE AND
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDY'S MATURE SO WE
CAN HAVE THE DATA WE NEED. NOW
FTA WRECK. JUSTIN URGENT NEED
TO A SAFE ENOUGH EX FOR COVID
NINETEEN. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ABBERLEY WITH ALL
INDUSTRY- AND ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS AND ACADEMIA- AS WELL
AS IN GOVERNMENT ON THAT. TODAY
WE HAD CONDITION ACTION TO
FACILITATE THE TIMELY
DEVELOPMENT OF SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE ACT BECAUSE ACT SEEMS
TO PREVENT COVID NINETEEN. BY
PROVIDING NEW GUIDANCE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THOSE
DEVELOPING COVID NINETEEN
VACCINES. AND THE GOAL OF THIS
GUIDANCE IS TO ASSIST IN THE
CLINICAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
ULTIMATELY HOPEFULLY THE
LICENSURE OF THE VACCINE FOR
THE PREVENTION OF COVID
NINETEEN. THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THIS GUIDANCE BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES REGULATORY
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARITY TO THE
VALVE IS WHAT IS FDA EXPECTING
TO SEE IN TERMS OF DATA.
SCIENCE CONTACT. US AND WE CAN
MAKE THE- BEST DECISION FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. NOW WHY THE
FDA IS COMMITTED TO EXPEDITING
THIS WORK WE WILL NOT CUT
CORNERS IN ORDER TO APPROVE THE
VACCINE. AND WILL MAKE CLEAR
THIS GUNS WHAT DATE ARE NEEDED
TO MEET OUR REGULATORY
STANDARDS. ARE CAUGHT WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR TIME LINE
WITH RESPECT TO VACCINE WE SEE
WITH DANISH NO. A FROM THERE
POINT VIEW THERE ARE MORE TO.
IN THE TOOLBOX FOR THE GREAT.
IN THIS COUNTRY I TO TREAT
PATIENTS WITH KOBE NINETEEN.
MEN FIND ADD LIKE TO ADD TO IT
THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID AND
THAT IS MASK WEARING. SOCIAL
DISTANCING HAND HYGIENE AND
OTHER FORMS FORMS OF HYGIENE
THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
AMERICA OPEN AGAIN. I'VE HEARD
FROM COLLEAGUES AROUND THE
COUNTRY MY FORMER COLLEAGUES IN
IN CANCER CARE VETERANS AND
FAMILIES NOBODY WANTS TO SHUT
DOWN AGAIN. OUR WAY OF KEEPING.
HIS WITH THE- PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DR HAN. UNDER AS YOU
CAN SEE WE'RE IN A MUCH BETTER
PLACE. WHETHER IT BE OF.
TESTING WHETHER BE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WHETHER IT
TO. OF THE VENTILATORS OR
WHETHER IT BE THE AVAILABILITY
OF MEDICINES THAT ARE SPEEDING
RELIEF TO AMERICANS STRUGGLING
WITH CORONAVIRUS. FUND IN IRAQ
AND I PROMISE YOU- THAT AS
PRESIDENT HAS DIRECTED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO BRING THE FULL
RESOURCES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BEAR IN SUPPORT
OF GOVERNORS AND STATES. THAT
ARE BEING IMPACTED BY THE
LATEST TOPIC OF THE CORONA
FIRST. BUT AS WE SAID AT THE
BEGINNING WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND WE ALL HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY. AND SO I ONE OF
THE US SURGEON GENERAL TO BRING
FOR YOUR REMARKS ABOUT. ABOUT
HOW EVERY AMERICAN CAN PLAY
THEIR PART- TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
OF TO PUT INTO PRACTICE THE-
THE KIND OF PERSONAL HABITS-
THAT WILL INSURE NOT YOU SHOULD
THEY PROTECT THEIR OWN HEALTH
OR THE HEALTH OF A FAMILY
MEMBER OR FRIEND BUT MOST
ESPECIALLY ASSISTANCE ALREADY.
WE SEE THAT. ROUGHLY HALF OF
THE NEW CASES IN TEXAS AND
FLORIDA WE ARE TOLD ARE. AMONG
AMERICANS UNDER THE AGE OF
THIRTY FIVE. FOR WHOM THE
THREAT OF SERIOUS OUTCOMES
CORONAVIRUS IS. REALLY LOW. BUT
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT PROTECTING
YOURSELF AS A YOUNG PERSON IT'S
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT ANYONE
WHO IS VULNERABLE. TO SERIOUS
OUTCOME WITH THE CORONAVIRUS IS
PROTECTED NO ONE. OF ANY AGE. I
WANT TO CONVERT LEE POSE. A
MOTHER A FATHER GRANDMOTHER
GRANDFATHER AND WITH SURGEON
GENERAL SHARE WITH US OF THE
KIND OF PRACTICES- THAT'LL MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR ALL OF US TO DO
OUR PART. TO SLOW THE SPREAD-
TO HEAL OUR LAND EVEN AS WE
CONTINUE TO OPEN UP AMERICA.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE. THANK
YOU MR VICE PRESIDENT FIRST
BEING HERE AT. PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE COMMISSIONED CORPS
HEADQUARTERS TODAY WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. END UP I JUST
WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY CANNOT
AFFORD TO LOSE FOCUS ON THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THE
KOBE NINETEEN IT HAD ON
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. COMPARED TO WHITES
AMERICAN INDIANS AND ALASKA
NATIVES ARE HOSPITALIZED AT
FIVE TIMES THE RATE. BLACK
AMERICANS HOSPITALIZED AT FOUR
AND A HALF TIMES THE RATE
HISPANICS THREE AND A HALF
TIMES THE RATE. THE FACT IS IF
VIRUSES EXPLOITING AND
EXACERBATING PRE EXISTING
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN THESE
DISPARATE OUTCOMES IN AN
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HEALTH A PART OF THE ANGER. THE
FRUSTRATION IN THE PIER THAT
RISKING MANIFEST IN PROTESTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY. THE FACT IS
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND SOCIAL
INJUSTICE OFTEN REVEALS ITSELF
THROUGH HEALTH INEQUITIES. IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF MY
OFFICER USING OUR UNIQUE
LEVERAGE INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE COMMISSIONED
CORPS TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HEALTHY. AT SECRETARY EIGHT
HOURS GRETCHEN WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AT HHS TO ADDRESS THESE
DISPARITIES LONG BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. BUT IN RESPONSE TO
THE PANDEMIC WE TAKEN A NUMBER
OF ADDITIONAL IMMEDIATE ACTIONS
AND IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BOTH
THE BURDEN OF DISEASE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE NOW AVAILABLE TO FOLKS
TO HELP RESPOND I WANT TO
QUICKLY RUN DOWN SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS. ADULT YOUR WHAT IS
LEADS ARE INCREASE IN COMMUNITY
BASED TESTING OVER SIX HUNDRED
SITES 70% OF THEM ARE IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A HIGH
SOCIAL VULNERABILITY INDEX
WHICH MEANS THEY'RE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SERVING
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIRTY THREE
NOW REQUIRES ALL TESTING DATA
REPORTED BY STATES INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON RACE ETHNICITY
AND DIP CODE. THIS MANDATE WILL
HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND WHO
IS MOST AFFECTED AND HOW TO
TARGET INTERVENTIONS ON THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. HHS
RECENTLY ALLOCATED FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO MEDICAID
PROVIDERS IN TEN BILLION TO
THINKING THAT HOSPITALS WHICH
SERVE LARGE NUMBERS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AMERICANS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ALSO INVESTED
CRITICAL RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS WHICH
I OFTEN SAY ARE BEST KEPT
SECRETS. INSURING THAT TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE AND TESTING
THAT THEY NEED. WE DON'T WANT
OUR FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS TO BE
SECRETS TO THE PEOPLE WHO MOST
CAN BENEFIT FROM THE AIR THAT
THEY RECEIVED THEIR- AND
SECRETARY EIGHT OR NOT THANK
YOU FOR THIS. INSTRUCTOR'S
OFFICE TO EX BUT I CALL TO
ACTION ON HYPERTENSION WHICH IS
THE NUMBER ONE RISK FACTOR FOR
COVID COMPLICATIONS. AND
MATERNAL MORTALITY. WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND I AM VERY
WORRIED ABOUT INFANT MORTALITY
AND MATERNAL MORTALITY GOING UP
IN THE MIDST OF COVID. BECAUSE
WOMEN ARE SCARED TO GO OUT AND
GET CARE. WE NEED TO SAFELY
REOPEN FOR THE PEOPLE. THE CARE
THEY NEED TO BE ON COVID. LAST
WEEK YOUR FAMILY WHILE I'M THAT
MORE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE WAS
AWARDED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
AS PART OF A COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENT WITH THE OFFICE OF
MINORITY HEALTH. THIS AFTER
WILL BE A MAJOR LEAP FORWARD
AND HELP US ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF
DELIVERING IMPORTANT COVID
NINETEEN UPDATES. AND
INFORMATION IN WAYS EVEN
THROUGH CHANNELS THE BEST REACH
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. AND
SPEAKING OF REACHING MINORITY
COMMUNITIES WE WERE REALLY
DIGGING IN IT'S A TO ENGAGEMENT
WITH OTHER FOLKS I HAD A PHONE
CALL. LAST WEEK WITH OVER A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
COMMUNITIES. JESSE JACKSON'S
RAINBOW PUSH COALITION. THE
NATIONAL HISPANIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK NURSES.
AND OVER A HUNDRED OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ON THE PHONE
CALL. IT'S A- HHS WORKING. TO
OUTREACH TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
GET THE INFORMATION OF THE
PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED TO BENEFIT
FROM. AND TO THE POINT OF THE
VP VISIT HERE TODAY. ONE OF THE
REASONS I'M PROUD TO BE A
LEADER IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE COMMISSIONED CORPS IS
OUR MISSION. TO SERVE THE
UNDERSERVED. HAVING A READY
RESERVE WHICH OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE MADE
EARLIER TODAY WILL AUGMENT OUR
EFFORTS TO ELIMINATE HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND ENSURE EVERYONE
HAS THE BEST CHANCE OF A LONG
AND HEALTHY LIFE. ONE OF EIGHT
UNIFORM THIS IS. PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE IS THE ONLY ONE
DEDICATED SOLELY TO PROTECTING
AND PROMOTING AMERICA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH. BY A NUMBER OF METRICS
WE ARE THE MOST DIVERSE
UNIFORMS SERVICE OVER 50% OF
OUR OFFICERS ARE FEMALE. AND
ONLY 40% IDENTIFY AS WHITE AND
NON HISPANIC. WE PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH SERVICES WERE
MOST OTHERS DO NOT GO THEY'RE
NOT GOING SOME CASES TO PROVIDE
CARE FOR VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. THE
BULK OF OUR OFFICERS RIGHT
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES HEALTH
SERVICES FACILITIES AND WE HAVE
A LARGE NUMBER OF OFFICERS IN
THE BUREAU OF PRISONS. TO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BY COVID
NINETEEN. WE SERVE ON THE FRONT
LINE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES MY FIRST
APPOINTMENT. WAS TO PORTO RICO
AND THE U. S. VIRGIN ISLANDS
AFTER THREE CATEGORY FIVE
HURRICANES IN A ROW. HIT THOSE
UNFORTUNATE TERRITORIES. WE
RESPOND QUICKLY TO NATURAL
DISASTERS DIVVIED OUT BREAKING
GLOBAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
LIKE A BOLA AS WELL AS SERVE ON
HUMANITARIAN MISSIONS. WE ALSO
ADVANCED INNOVATION SCIENCE AND
WORK AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MEDICAL CHALLENGES LIKE COVID
NINETEEN. CANCER IN THE OPIOID
KITE CRISIS PROVIDING NEW
TREATMENTS AND CURES. WHICH
LEADS ME TO MY FINISH. WE ARE
IN A MUCH BETTER PLACE TO TREAT
COVID THAN WHAT WE WERE. TWO
MONTHS AGO FOUR MONTHS AGO EVEN
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. WE HEARD
AFTER A FLOOD CHECK TALK ABOUT
HOW WE ARE BETTER SUPPLIED THEM
WHAT WE WERE DOES IT MEAN THAT
IT'S MISSION ACCOMPLISHED BUT
WE ARE IN A MUCH BETTER PLACE
NOW WITH P. P. AND WITH OTHER
SUPPLIES. WITH STEROIDS FROM
DEATH TO BE A CONVALESCENT
PLASMA IF YOU GET COVID
NINETEEN WE ARE IN A MUCH
BETTER POSITION TO GET YOU OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL SAFELY. BUT
PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S ALL ABOUT
PREVENTION. AND I'M A LEADER IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE
CORPS. SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
PREVENTION. MIGHT SURGEON
GENERAL'S PRESCRIPTION WHICH I
FIRST ANNOUNCED YOU ALL. WAY
BACK IN MARCH. THREE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE. KNOW YOUR RISK ARE
YOU AT HIGH RISK ARE YOU AT LOW
RISK ARE YOU AN INTERMEDIATE
RISK FOR COVID NINETEEN. NUMBER
TO KNOW YOUR CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
YOU IN A COMMUNITY WHERE RATES
ARE GOING UP ARE YOU IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE RATES ARE GOING
DOWN. ARE YOU GOING TO A PLACE
WHERE YOU CAN TAKE PRECAUTIONS
LIKE BEING OUTSIDE AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING. NUMBER THREE KNOW
HOW TO STAY SAFE AND THAT
INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM MAKING
SURE WE'RE TAKING BASIC
PRECAUTIONS TO STAYING HOME IF
YOU'RE AT HIGH RISK OR YOU'RE
GOING TO A HIGH RISK PLACE. THE
FACT IS WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN CASES IN INCREASE
IN HOSPITALIZATIONS IN THOSE
UNDER FORTY. SO WE NEED
EVERYONE TO FOLLOW OUR
PREVENTIVE GUIDELINES. A HOME
IF YOU'RE SICK. STAY HOME IF
YOU'RE VULNERABLE AND AGAIN WE
KNOW PEOPLE ARE MORE VULNERABLE
AS THEY GET OLDER BUT THEY'RE
ALSO VULNERABLE IF THEY HAVE
HYPERTENSION DIABETES AND
OBESITY. WASH YOUR HANDS OR USE
HAND SANITIZER FREQUENTLY WENT
OUT. MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
DISTANCE BETWEEN YOU AND OTHERS
WHEN YOU'RE OUT. AND PLEASE
PLEASE PLEASE WEAR A BASE
COVERING WHEN YOU GO OUT IN
PUBLIC. IT IS NOT AN
INCONVENIENCE IT IS NOT A
SUPPRESSION OF YOUR FREEDOM. IT
ACTUALLY IS A VEHICLE TO
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IT ADDS TO
YOUR CONVENIENCE IN YOUR
FREEDOM BECAUSE IT ALLOWS US TO
OPEN UP MORE PLACES AND IT
ALLOWS THE PLACES TO STAY OPEN.
WHEN YOU DO NOT WEAR FACE
COVERING WE END UP IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU SEE HIGHER
RATES OF THE V. SPREAD AND YOU
END UP HAVING TO CLOSE PLACE.
THIS MASK THE FACE COVERING
ACTUALLY IT AN INSTRUMENT OF
FREEDOM FOR AMERICANS IF WE ALL
USE IT. YOUNG PEOPLE I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE BY BY ASKING YOU
TO WORK WITH US PLEASE WORK
WITH US BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
MANY OF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
NOT AT RISK OR YOU'RE NOT AT
HIGHER RISK BUT WE NEED ALL OF
YOU TO HELP PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE BUT ALSO TO PROTECT
YOURSELVES IN TO GIVE YOU MORE
OPTIONS IF YOU WANT. THE RETURN
OF COLLEGE FOOTBALL THIS YEAR.
WHERE A FACE COVERING. IF YOU
WANT A CHANCE THE PROBLEM NEXT
SPRING WHERE A FACE COVERING. I
HAD A- BUT THE NORTH CAROLINA
RADIO STATION IF YOU WANT TO
SEE NORTH CAROLINA BEAT DUKE IN
PERSON THIS YEAR. WHERE A FACE
COVERING AND I GREW UP IN
MARYLAND AND IN INDIANA SO
SORRY DUKE BUT I AS LONG AS
SOMEBODY BEAT YOU I'M OKAY WITH
THAT. IF YOU WANT TO GO ON
SPRING BREAK. NEXT MARCH NEXT
APRIL WHERE A FACE COVERING. I
WANT YOU ALL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT MEANT TO BE
PESSIMISTIC. I'M ACTUALLY
CONFIDENT BASED ON THE DATA
WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD THAT IF WE
DO THE RIGHT THINGS WE ACTUALLY
CAN RE OPEN AND STAY OPEN. OVER
TIME IF A LONG TIME. IN JUST A
FEW WEEKS WE CAN DRASTICALLY
SAY THINGS GOING THE WRONG
DIRECTION BUT WE ALSO CAN
DRASTICALLY SEE THINGS IMPROVE.
IF YOU ARE WILL COMMIT TO
WEARING THE FACE COVERING BEEN
TAKING BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH
PRECAUTIONS. AT THE NATION'S DR
AT AMERICAN DOCTOR I WANT YOU
TO KNOW I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE
THAT WE CAN VERY QUICKLY SEE
NEW CASE COUNTS GO DOWN. AND WE
CAN REOPEN WE CAN GET BACK TO
SCHOOL TO WORK TO WORSHIP IN
THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL. BUT WE'VE
ALL GOT TO DO OUR PART. IT'S UP
TO YOU AMERICA. IF YOU JOIN IN
AND WE ALL DO OUR PART WE ALL
WIN. OKAY. THANK YOU DOCTOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A GOOD
TIME FOR A FEW QUESTIONS- GREAT
MARCH THANK YOU MR VICE
PRESIDENT WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE MASS TODAY WE SAY
CASES RISING IS THERE ANY
CONSIDERATION FOR MAKING MASKS
MANDATORY OR- PENALIZING STATES
THAT AREN'T FOLLOWING THE CDC
GUIDELINES PROPERLY. BUT THE
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD FROM
EARLY IN THE CORONAVIRUS IS. WE
HAVE FOLLOWED. THE MODEL OF
THAT IS THAT. WE DESCRIBE FROM
EARLY ON WHICH WAS TO HAVE A
NATIONAL RESPONSE IT WAS
FEDERALLY SUPPORTED. STATE
MANAGED AND LOCALLY. SERVICES
PEOPLE MOST IMPACTED BY THE
DISEASE HAD WITHIN THE THAT
STATES WOULD MANAGE THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT WE WOULD
MARSHAL THE RESOURCES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
PRIVATE ECONOMY TO SUPPORT
THAT- AND WILL CONTINUE TO USE
THAT MODEL- RISK SAYING THE
DECISIONS THE GOVERNORS ARE
MAKING. THEIR BEEN STATES THAT
HAVE- DELEGATED AUTHORITY TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH REGARD
TO FACIAL COVERINGS AND- WE
SUPPORT THOSE DECISIONS BY
GOVERNORS BUT- AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S TWELVE STATES THAT
WE'RE WATCHING VERY CAREFULLY
NOW. THAT HAVE BOTH RISING
BASES AND RISING POSITIVITY
THERE'S FOUR STATES WERE 50% OF
THE NEW CASES ARE HAPPENING.
AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT- THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S HEALTH OFFICIALS IN
THOSE STATES OF THE TO RESPOND.
IT IS AN MOST AFFECT THERE AND
THAT'S OKAY TO OUR SUCCESS THUS
FAR MAKING. IS THIS PLANNED. IS
WHERE THE NORTHWEST THEN IN THE.
NEW ORLEANS MICHIGAN OF COURSE
THE COUNTRY. WE'VE MADE SURE
THAT YOU GOT AND HEALTH OF THE
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY
NEED IT AND WE EX. AND CONTINUE
TO EXPIRE OUR FULL SUPPORT FOR
MEASURES AND JUST. THAT THEY
MADE. SOME CORY HAVE. AT
SECRETARY IS OUR. FIRST TIME
WHEN IT'S ASK YOU I'M YOUR
DOCTOR FIVE DAYS THAT TODAY I.
I STARTED TO GO DOWN AND NOW
IT'S GOING BACK UP. NOT FAILURE.
WELL WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IN THE WAY
IT'S IMPACTED THE UNITED STATES.
WE FIRST OBSERVED THE CASE.
EMERGING IN SEATTLE AND THEN IN
THE NORTHEAST AND IN ORLEANS
AND IN MICHIGAN IN IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL AREA I HAD ITS OWN
IMPACTED. BYE BY INSTITUTING
THE GUIDANCE AND THE MEASURES
THAT WE INSTITUTED SUPPORTING
GOVERNORS WE WERE ABLE TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE IN EACH OF
THOSE AREAS- AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
WITH THE COOPERATION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE- IN THE F.
THIRTY REPLACE INSTEAD ACROSS A-
THAT WILL ABLE TO SEE THE
SPREAD AND FLATTEN. THE CURVE
SOUTH AS WELL. BUT WHAT WHAT
POURTANT UNDERSTAND THAT WE- IN
IN THE OUT FOR. OF THERE WE'VE
SEEN SOME. OF AFTER WORKERS WE
SAME INSTANCES OF. DISCRETE
POPULATION. THAT THE- CORE TO
WHAT THEY TELL US OUT OF INTO
IS HALF OF THOSE PEOPLE. THAT
ARE TEN FOR. OUR OUR OWN. THIS
BECAUSE SIX THAT WE'VE HAD WITH.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TELL PEOPLE
ALL ACROSS THIS WHO ARE A
SYMPTOM IT IT I THINK IT IT'S A
IT'S WORTH NO THAT OF THAT
EARLY IN PROCESS WHICH FOR
TEXTING EXCLUSIVE ON THAT WE'RE
GONNA OR WERE CARE WERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAD. NOW WE LIVE
TEST ANYONE WHO COME TO IT SITE
OR COME TO THERE WILL FARM IN
IN IT'S ARGUED THAT SOME OF NEW
K. THAT WE STUDIED ARE A RISK
OF THE FOR THAT WE'RE TEN FIVE
HUNDRED TO SAY HUNDRED.
AMERICAN TODAY THAT BEING SAID
I THINK THIS MAY POINT OF THE
OF IT. TIM SCOTT THE
CORONAVIRUS TO BE ABLE TO PUSH.
WE ABLE TO. UNITY TO PROTECT
THE MOST VULNERABLE BUT BUT WE
YOU LOOK AT THE X. SUCCESS
UNITED STATES THE HIS SUCCESS
WE HAD IN TEN. IT'S WELL UNDER
THAT IT THAT'S CONTRIBUTED PART.
ACT. TO IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
FRANK UNTIL WEEKS AGO BECAUSE-
OF OUR TESTING WE WERE TO STEAL
THE TIME. DID BEFORE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO SLOW THE SPREAD AND
FLATTEN THE CURVE AGAIN. THE
SECTOR. GRETCHEN DID YOU EVER
YEAH. WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK
IF YOU ARE A WORKING PARENT.
YOUR KID IS NOT IN SCHOOL ACT
IS PRETTY MUCH AN IMPOSSIBILITY
AND SO AS AS WE'RE TRYING TO
HEAR DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
PRESENTING IN THE PANTS FROM
FALLING DOWN BUT THEY'LL BE A
LOT OF STAGGERED. SCHEDULES
MEETING KIDS IN OUR SCHOOL
START OUR. SCHOOL EVERY SECOND
DAY. GOVERNMENT DEALING. ACT
SCHOOLS HOW PARENTS
INVESTIGATOR HIRING MORE
TEACHERS INVEST IN BUILDING
YOUR CLASS. DEVELOPING FOR
PARENTS AND THEY HAVE SOMEWHERE
TO LEAVE THEIR KIDS DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TODAY. TO HELP VETERANS WELL SO
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
PROVIDING AND SO THE CDC TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
THE BEST INFORMATION POSSIBLE
ABOUT HOW THEY COULD BRING KIDS
BACK SAFELY- SO FOR INSTANCE.
YOU NEED TO YOU DON'T NEED TO
HAVE THEIR OWN IN AUDITORIUMS
YOU CAN HAVE A SOME OF THOSE
CONGREGATE SETTINGS THAT YOU
WOULD NOT YOU WOULD OF WHAT YOU
MIGHT IF YOUR KIDS. NEED HAVE
THE DUST. THIS IS WITHIN THE
CLASS. THAT IF. EATING AND
CAFETERIA HAVE THEM EATING
THEIR DAY. SO THERE'S- THAT WE
TAKE THAT LARGER. CAN WITH WHAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACIAL COVERINGS
WHEN YOU CAN'T SOCIAL DISTANCE
OF COURSE ENSURING GOOD
PERSONAL HYGIENE. OF THESE THE
KINDS OF WHICH IS VERY COMMON
SENSE STEPS AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT- WE'RE GONNA WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS AT OUR
SCHOOL. HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WELL AS OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE-
SO THAT WE HAVE EARLY EARLY
SPOTTING IF WE'RE SEEING.
MARGINS OF JUST. IT ISN'T AND
SO THAT'S PART OF WHAT- ADVISER
WHAT HAS BEEN WORKING ON. OUR
IS REALLY ENHANCING THE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS AND
TESTING SYSTEMS FOR IN THE
POLLING THE SPOKE ABOUT THE-
HELLO. VERY LARGE SCALE. UP AT
SCREEN. WITH FOR UP IN THE
EVENT OF ANY POSITIVE CASES.
GEORGE GREW OF PEOPLE. THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT IF
YOU'RE DISTRICT THAT ALREADY
CROWDED CLASSROOMS YOU DON'T
HAVE SPACE FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO SPREAD OUT THE
CLASSROOM LETTER FOR THE SECTOR
OF EDUCATION ON THAT ONE. BUT
BUT WHAT WILL PROVIDE THE
HEALTH SUPPORT FOR THEM. BUT
END DOCTORATE REPORTED TO TASK
FORCE TODAY THAT WE PUBLISHED
TODAY- GUIDANCE FOR- HIGHER
EDUCATION COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS K.
THROUGH TWELVE. AND AT THE
PRESENT TIME FORTY SEVEN STATES
HAVE ALREADY ISSUED GUIDANCE-
ABOUT. RE OPENING THEIR SCHOOLS
AND- I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I ARE TIRED
MENSURATION ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO GET MY KIDS BACK
TO SCHOOL THIS FALL AND SINCE.
WE GOTTA GO BACK TO SCHOOL WE
DO IN THE BACK. I'M TALKING
ABOUT YOU WANT US FIVE AS TO
SAY YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBER OF
CASES RISING TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND I THANK YOU THE
CURRENT TRAJECTORY- I WON'T
CHANGE. WHAT IS CURRENT TALK
WITH BECAUSE I'M HERE THAT
EVERY SEEMS FINE FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. WELL FIRST AND
FOREMOST I HOPE WHAT YOU HEARD
TODAY IS WE'RE READY. WE WERE
MORE PREPARED NEVER BEFORE. AND
I WANT THE PEOPLE EARLY IN THE
TWELVE STATES THAT WE SEE
RISING CASES AND RISING
POSITIVITY- TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
WITH THEM AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE EXPAND TESTING
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNORS AND
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO IDENTIFY
PEOPLE COMMUNITIES. CONTRACT IS
EASING THREE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
NO SYMPTOMS WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE NEXT AND DISTRIBUTE
NATIONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
BLOW YOU HEARD FROM. I AM A
FULL OF CHECK THAT- HOSPITALS
ALL THE AFFECTED AREAS HAVE
ABUNDANT SUPPLIES OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. WE MAKE
SURE THE VENTILATORS AND OTHER
CRITICAL MEDICAL APPARATUS ARE
AVAILABLE AND THIS WEEK WE'RE
DISTRIBUTING THEM. ON LAST A
TRUMP SHOULD RENT DOES APPEAR
TO ALL FIFTY STATES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT MEDICINE. IS
AVAILABLE NOT SO MY ANSWERS
WERE READY- WERE READY TO
RESPOND- AND WE ARE RESPONDING-
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. TO ANSWER THAT THE
CORE OF YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW
WE LITERALLY SAW CASES-
DECLINING PRECIPITOUSLY BECAUSE
OF WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE DONE- THERE WAS A- THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE- AS THE THIS WAS
A RESULT OF STATE'S RE OPENING
BUT- SIS AND FLORIDA- AND OTHER
STATES INVOLVED HERE. REAL OPEN
VERY EARLY THANK. INTO THE
FACED GUY. THAT WE PUBLISH OPEN
UP AMERICA AGAIN. AND THROUGH
THE COURSE OF THE ENTIRE MONTH
OF MAY AND INTO EARLY JUNE.
THEIR CASES WERE LOW INSTEAD
AND UP THEIR POSITIVITY RATES
WERE RISING BUT SOMETHING
CHANGED ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO AND
BECAUSE THE EXTRAORDINARY
CAPACITY WE HAVE FOR TESTING.
WE WERE ABLE TO OBSERVE THAT TO
WORK WITH GOVERNORS IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOW IS RESPONDING.
VAIDIKA INFORMATION WITH
GOVERNORS PROVIDING THE SUPPORT.
THE DECISIONS. THAT HAVE OUR
FULL SUPPORT THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL AS AS THOSE MEASURES TO
BEFORE. OF THAT WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PUT ALL THESE PRINCIPLES INTO
PRACTICE OF THE WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT OF SLOWING THE SPREAD
AND FLATTENING THE CURVE BUT
WE'RE WE'RE LEANING INTO THIS
EFFORT AND WILL CONTINUE. TO
LEAN INTO IT. ABOUT IF YOU'RE
READY THREE. STRASBOURG SO YOU
SEE A REALLY EMPHASIS ABOUT
THIRTY MASS. BUT IT SEEMS THAT
AS JULY FOURTH IS COMING AROUND
AMERICANS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
TO CELEBRATE THE INDEPENDENCE
THERE'S A KIND OF INCONSISTENT.
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGE. I WASN'T
GOING TO SOUTH DAKOTA FOR THIS
EVENT WONDERFUL BEING SOCIAL.
PEOPLE REQUIRED VAST VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN HIMSELF HE SAID.
PATRIOTISM IS FOR. I'M
WONDERING KNOW YOU SEE PRESENCE
ANYWHERE A RED HAT. WHY CAN'T
HIS EXAMPLE OF WEARING A MASK
ALSO HAVE MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WELL THE QUESTIONS FOR
THE MASS. AND PUT SEVEN HIGH
AND YOU FOR A STRONG. IN KURTZ.
ABOUT MASK. BUT LET ME LET ME
SAY WE BELIEVE THAT. THE
AMERICAN SHOULD WEAR A MASK
WHENEVER STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES INDICATE THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE. OR WHENEVER SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS NOT POSSIBLE AND
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO CONVEY.
THAT MESSAGE- BUT- YOU KNOW
THIS IS A THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OF. HAVE ALREADY DEMONSTRATED
IN THE WAY THAT WE SAW THE
EXTRAORDINARY PROGRESS IN THE
GREATER NEW YORK CITY AREA THE
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS IN THE
GREATER NEW ORLEANS AREA IN
DETROIT AND OTHER PLACES WE
KNOW THAT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE EQUIPPED. WITH
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
PLAY A ROLE- TO PROTECT THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND NEIGHBORS IN
PARTICULAR THE HOLD THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE. THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL PUT THOSE INTO PRACTICE
BUT WE'RE- WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO OF- RESPECT- THE RIGHT OF
EVERY AMERICAN BUT ENCOURAGE
THEM TO LISTEN TO STATE AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES- THE GUIDANCE
THAT THEY HAVE- BUT- WE
HONESTLY- WE HONESTLY COULDN'T
BE MORE INSPIRED BY WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SO FAR. AND AS
WE SEE IN THESE TWELVE STATES
THAT HAVE RISING CASES AND
RISING POSITIVITY WERE. WE
REMAIN CONFIDENT- CONFIDENT NOT
ONLY IN THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
WERE ABLE TO BRING TO BEAR.
BECAUSE OF THE WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT THE WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
INITIATED BUT- WE'RE CONFIDENT
THAT- THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL RESPOND THEY'LL PUT THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
NEIGHBORS FIRST. EVEN AS WE
CONTINUE TO. OPEN UP AMERICA.
ABOUT READ RESIDENT. THANK
QUESTIONS AND CLEAR LEADERSHIP
COMPANY FROM. FOR YES I WANT A
BETTER PLACE NOW THAN WE WERE
TO AND MONTHS AGO AND IN MANY
STATES THAT THAT OF THE BACKED
THIS UP THAT SAID. ARE YOU IN
THE PAST FORCE MEMBERS CONTEND
WITH THE LENGTH OF TIME IT'S
TAKEN TO GET US TO THIS POINT
AND I'LL PROBABLY. BOLTON WELL
I COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
DONE. IN THE COURSE OF THIS
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC. BEGINNING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES. WE DIDN'T HAVE A
SINGLE CASE. OF PERSON TO
PERSON TRANSMISSION OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL FROM CHINA
AT THE END OF JANUARY INSTEAD
OF THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE. HE INITIATED
EFFORTS THAT- THAT WOULD SET
INTO MOTION AT THE FDA THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF A VACCINE THAT
WAS ABLE TO GO TO ITS FIRST
CLINICAL TRIAL IN RECORD TIME
OF SIXTY TWO DAYS. HE PULLED HE
INITIATED THROUGH THE TASK
FORCE BRINGING TOGETHER PRIVATE
SECTOR FIRMS AND- LITERALLY OF
AN EFFORT TO REINVENT. INITIAL
TESTING IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA- WE STOOD UP AND NOT
JUST AN AIR BRIDGE BUT-
WHATEVER PULLINGER CALLS A
CONTROL TOWER WHERE WE MARSHAL
ALL THE RESOURCES OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND WE WERE ABLE
TO DIRECT BILLIONS OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- MASKS AND
GLOVES AND GOWNS. AND TO THE
POINT OF THE NEED WHAT YOU
HEARD MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT OUR
OUR RESPONSE HAS BEEN AT THE
FIFTH PRESENCE DIRECTION WE
MADE SURE THAT STATES HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT.
IT'S IT IT DEFINED OUR APPROACH
TO THIS PANDEMIC AS IT. AS IT.
HAD IT'S HEARTBREAKING IMPACT.
IN NEW YORK STATE AND NEW
JERSEY AND CONNECTICUT IN THE
ENVIRONS AND- END UP IN IT IT'S
THAT APPROACH FOCUSING
PARTICULARLY ON THOSE TWELVE
STATES TODAY- THAT THAT WE SEE
RISING CASES AND POSITIVITY
THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
DRIVE FORWARD. A TO MEET THIS
MOMENT. BUT I'M I'M VERY PROUD
OF THE PARTNERSHIP WE'VE HAD
WITH GOVERNORS AROUND THE
COUNTRY I'M PROUD OF THE- OF
THE WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH PRESIDENT TRUMP
INITIATED BUT- BE HONEST WITH
YOU I'M JUST MOST PROUD OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. OF THE VISIT.
THE COMPASSION. THE
COOPERATION. IN THE FACE. BUT
I'VE SEEN ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND IT GIVES ME GREAT
CONFIDENCE AS WE GO FORWARD.
THE WE SEE THIS NEW OUTBREAK IN
STATES ACROSS THE SOUTH- THAT
ONCE AGAIN ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. OUR PARTNERS AT THE
STATE LEVEL THIS GREAT TEAM AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. ARE GONNA NEED
TO SMALLMAN AND WORD SLOW THE
SPREAD WE'RE GONNA FLATTEN THE
CURVE. AND SAVE LIVES THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK.
THIS THE WHITE FOR.